katia bonjour alors vous suivez pour
nous ce cortège parisien en direction le
palais bourbon
oui nous avons passé le louvre en effet
cette partie de la place de l'opéra pour
ce rassemblement de à l'appel de trois
syndicats fo sud et solidaires mais
évidemment de nombreux grévistes
d'autres syndicats sont ici aujourd'hui
ainsi que des gels et je n'ai droit d y
avoir environ 2000 personnes ici une
mobilisation
en tout cas même s'il n'ya pas des
dizaines de milliers de personnes
elle est bonne enfant bruyante est tout
à fait consistante pour cette journée
les syndicats avaient promis une journée
noire dans les transports pour ce jour
d'examen du projet de loi de la réforme
des retraites c'est le premier jour de
cet examen
d'où cette mobilisation je suis
actuellement avec moi m 12 ou rennes qui
est conducteur de métro et militant unsa
alors bonjour monsieur vous aurez
d'aujourd'hui pour vous c'était
important cette mobilisation
oui fait du moins c'est important parce
qu'on avait commencé le 5 décembre et on
avait
pris un engagement avec ensemble des
salariés d'être présent à chaque date
importante de ce projet de loi
donc on avait lancé une grève illimitée
et lors des ag on avait pris la décision
de marquer le coup pour chaque date
importante est allé sur les intercoms
donc on avait fait la date du 24 il y
avait une présentation du dossier au
conseil des ministres
hélas il était important aujourd'hui
d'être présent dans la rue pour
manifester notre opposition à ce projet
là alors qu'il passe pour la première
fois au parlement pour ça alors vous
vous aviez prédit une journée noire dans
les transports c'est pas exactement le
cas il ya environ six lignes perturbées
connaît-il de la grève aujourd'hui à la
ratp
au niveau des conducteurs de métro
aujourd'hui on a eu un taux de grévistes
de 30 à 35% en moyenne
après bon on était conscient que ça
serait compliqué les collègues ont plus
de 50 ans de grève ont eu des fiches de
paye à 0 ils attendent une réelle
mobilisation générale donc bon on a eu
des petites oppositions aussi avec il ya
eu des petites polémiques avec d'autres
par rapport à la date par rapport à
celle de l'interpro et pour nous de
toute manière
la légitimité c'était les âges et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a maintenu celle du
est-ce que depuis décembre le mois de
grève extrêmement fortes dans les
transports il ya des inventions qui
concerne les droits que demandaient les
salari notamment m alors pour les
salariés des tpe à la demande numéro un
c'était le retrait du projet au début de
la grève on avait à peu près
81% de conducteurs de métro enfin
d'agents ratp concernés par la réforme à
partir d'un moment on est descendu à
plus grand pour cent de l'agent ratp
concernés par la réforme
mais pour nous c'est pas c'est pas
l'avancé qu'on attendait l'avancé qu'on
attendait c'est en retrait du projet
vous avez encore cet espoir de retrait
de réforme aujourd'hui si on est là oui
sinon on ne serait pas là aujourd'hui
voilà donc c'est qu'on a toujours
confiance et et on pense que la
mobilisation est que à un moment donné
peut-être ce gouvernement va tendre une
oreille se rendent compte que son projet
des néfastes
merci beaucoup m'amène vous aurez le
suivons cette situation dans ce cortège
intersyndical de trois syndicats ainsi
que de nombreux grévistes des gilet
jaune des avocats qui se dirige vers
l'assemblée nationale merci beaucoup
catia pour ces précisions katia
technique au coeur du cortège qui s'est
élancé de la place de l'opéra pour
rejoindre le palais bourbon